- On this episode, I
have five New York Jets
asking me questions.
You ask questions.
And I answer them.
This is
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hello, everybody.
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 138?
- [Male] Seven.
- Seven of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Is a very special show.
DRock, why don't you go
into the panoramic right now
editing of the office, as you can tell,
the Al Toon starting lineup jerseys.
Don Maynard hall of famer, Mr. Decker.
You probably see the Mike Tyson stuff
and some other random
weird stuff. The Ali stuff.
But very heavy New York Jet based office.
This is AJ and I's office.
We keep it pretty non-fancy.
This is a very special episode
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
I primed it yesterday.
I'm very excited about this.
This is the NFL, specifically
New York Jets, preview show.
If I am somewhat lucky or
somehow we get to next year,
we'll do it again.
And on this show five, my lucky number,
five New York Jets ask me
questions for the show.
So, Stunwin, show them.
Don't be scared, Andrew.
- I don't want to block his view.
- Stunwin, let's get into the J-e-t-s.
Jets, Jets, Jets Show.
- [Steve] All right. Ready? First one.
- Hey, Gary. This is Ryan
Fitzpatrick of the New York Jets.
- [Gary] My quarterback.
- I wanted to ask you about franchises.
Specifically, fast food
chains and the pros and cons
of getting involved with that business.
And the second part of that question,
how much money does Chick-fil-A lose
in being closed on Sundays?
Thanks. Look forward to your response.
- Fitz, super excited for
the starting quarterback
to start off this tremendous show.
First of all, epic beard.
I mean, geez Louise.
I thought I was bringing
it a couple months ago.
That thing is a beast.
Super excited.
A little quick shout out to
my brother-in-law, Alex Klein.
I'd yelled at him
profusely in 2009 and '10,
telling him Fitzpatrick was
better than our quarterback.
And, so, now I get my
chance five years later
to have Fitz QB this team up.
I'm excited to see you Sunday, Fitz.
Great question, you know.
You'd expect that from a Harvard grad.
I think the QSR business
is really intriguing.
Once dominated by McDonald's, Burger King,
couple of other players,
Wendy's, Pizza Hut,
things of that nature.
What we're seeing now is fast casual
and a whole revolution.
Whether it's Shake Shack, Chipotle,
different things of that nature.
And then a bunch of sub
brands popping up everywhere.
So many of my entrepreneurial friends
are jumping into the space
higher quality food,
different marketing tactics.
I think we're gonna see
the biggest shift in
quick serve restaurants that we've seen
in the last 50 years
happen over the next 20.
And, so, for entrepreneurs out there
I think it's a very
intriguing business model.
It's a tough business.
The restaurant business
is a tough business,
but when it hits, it hits for real.
And, so, I'm a big fan of the industry.
I've been looking at it.
I've been looking, and
poking, and prodding into
is there any opportunities
for me to get involved in it?
Here a little fun fact,
and if you in Jersey know,
Wine Library sits right
next to a Taco Bell.
Dad and I just bought that
Taco Bell a couple months ago.
It's sitting empty for extra parking.
I've been thinking about coming up--
Staphon, get in here.
I've been thinking about
creating some brand from scratch.
So, I'm looking for any
chef partners out there
that have always wanted
to do premium hotdogs
or some other random idea.
I'm open for business.
So, Fitz, I think it's
an interesting industry
with a lot of opportunity,
with the biggest shift
in it's opportunities
in maybe a half a century coming up.
As for Chick-fil-A, they lose
a ton of business on Sundays.
But I think, for the people
that know that business
and the family that runs it,
they're more passionate about
the reasons they're closed for that.
And I respect that
everybody's got the things
that matter to them most.
For example, the Jets matter to me most.
If, during Sunday's game at 1:00 o'clock,
at 1:47 I get 8,000 texts
emergency, emergency, and I look,
and I'm told by friends and family that
the liquor industry and the internet
have been shut down forever,
I could care less.
All I want to make sure is that
the Jets are whipping the Browns' faces.
So, everybody's got their own religion.
That's my answer.
All right. Let's keep it going.
- Gary, what's going on?
This is Brandon Marshall.
- [Gary] B Marshall.
- Question. What can I do now
to set up myself for business
when I'm done playing ball?
Thank you.
- Brandon, first of all,
thank you for helping me
curate this tremendous show.
I'm super excited.
As you can tell, by wearing
your number 15 t-shirt.
You're gonna rebrand 15
in green the proper way.
You like that, Andrew?
There's a lot of things you could be doing
to prepare for life after football.
I think a lot of it has
to do around networking
with the right people
in the business world,
or any other place you want to go into.
Especially when you have celebrity status
as a football player you can
leverage that during your time.
It's amazing, I've watched this happen
with a lot of my athlete friends.
It's amazing.
The level of leverage lost the
second a player stops playing
from literally the day before.
It's incredible.
And, so, while you're active
being in the New York market
is a tremendous opportunity.
You have a huge opportunity
to leverage that,
because you have access
to so many individuals.
So, what I think you have to do is
reverse engineer what
you want to accomplish,
and then start networking
and using that celebrity
to get access to people
and start learning,
and start executing, start
making real relationships.
So they're tangible relationships,
and they're not built on,
"Oh, I want to hang out with
my favorite football player."
They're real relationships post-football
where you actually have that rapport.
And you go into business, or motivation,
or nonprofit, or whatever is your driver.
And, so, there's that.
Brandon, I'm gonna give you
a little prediction here.
This is one of the toughest secondaries
you're facing this Sunday with Cleveland,
which concerns me,
but I still see six catches for 89 yards,
and a sit back touchdown.
- [Camera Man] It's rolling.
- Oh, it's rolling. Gary, Eric Decker.
- [Gary] Eric Decker. Jersey right there.
- I want to know how can
athletes use social media
to expand upon their brand.
- Eric, I think one of
the biggest, first of all,
super pumped you and B Marshall tag team.
I love this. Best receiving
core we've had in a long time.
Probably since '98.
I think athletes need to engage
with their fans a lot more.
You know, just pushing out like,
"Come to my nonprofit event."
"Buy my jersey,"
"Support my friend."
You obviously have a
celebrity spouse as well.
So, bring exposure to her stuff.
All celebrities, not just athletes,
are always pushing,
pushing, pushing, pushing.
Like, you know, "Come and see my stuff,"
"do this stuff," "do this
for me," "do this for me."
How about doing something for them?
The amount of people,
Eric, right now on Twitter
that are saying, "Eric
Decker, can't wait."
A lot of people saying,
"Eric Decker, you're so hot."
You know, why don't you engage
with some of those people,
and literally just use Twitter
video, like I love to use,
grab your phone, go to Twitter, reply.
I'm gonna do it right now.
You know what? DRock,
I'ma do it right now.
Let's just randomly pick somebody.
This is the way to do it, right?
You'll probably edit and
do whatever you're doing.
Here we go. Just hitting notifications.
Boom. There we go.
Let's see who says something.
Here we go, D-Rock said something.
DRock, get out of here.
Let's just find something here.
All right. Let's keep
going. Just scrolling.
A lot of regramming. Let's
see if somebody says hello.
Dustin Riddle, "Gary
Vee, have a great day."
So, I hit the reply button.
I hit the camera on
the bottom left corner.
I hit the camera on the top right corner.
I switch it to camera mode.
I flip it to selfie mode,
and now I forgot the
God damned guy's name.
Son of a bitch.
Let's exit out. Let's go back. Done.
Dustin, got it.
All right, Dust. Here we go.
Here we go.
Yeah, that's what happens
when you do it live.
Dustin, video, camera.
Dustin, it's Gary Vee. I
appreciate that, brother.
I hope you have a wonderful,
wonderful weekend.
Thanks, man.
And that's it.
And now, I'm actually
bringing value to Dustin.
Eric, the amount of people that
when you wave to them in the crowd,
or you throw them a glove,
or you say hey, they go crazy.
You can scale that.
You can scale that on social
and create real depth.
You know, real depth.
The amount of people that
I've done those videos for
and just engaged with and said hey.
Then the next day go out and
buy Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
Or when Jason Glenn,
number 58, special teamer
gave me some daps at a Jets Patriots game,
when I was on the field and just said hey.
The next day I went and custom ordered
his jersey at $100 bucks.
That is what's happening.
It's very easy for you to get
into the trenches of Twitter
at scale and engage with your fan base.
And I highly, highly recommend that.
Let's do it.
- [Steve] Right.
- Are we good?
Hey Gary, Demario Davis.
- [Gary] Double D.
- Linebacker, New York Jets,
number 56, aka Double D.
Coming at you.
I got a question. When it
comes to start up companies
is it better to use your own
capitol, raise money for it,
or to take out a loan?
Hit me back with an answer, please, sir.
- I love it. Demario, got
a couple fun facts for you.
Number one, you maybe 56 now,
but you're looking at a human being,
probably the only one who has
a number 49 Demario Davis,
because when you were drafted
out of the third round by us
two funny things happened.
One, I ordered your jersey immediately,
because I knew what Double D
was gonna bring to the table,
because I got a story that you don't know.
Which is, I got some friends in that team
that I don't like as
much called the Patriots.
And when you were drafted
in their draft room,
they were really sad and scared.
Which excited me, because I
knew Double D was gonna bring it
to the New York Jets.
You didn't know that, huh, Staphon?
You didn't know that, Double D, but I did.
Now, let me answer your question.
All three work. They all can work.
Again, if you're asking
for selfishly, for you.
If you got some start up ideas,
I think that raising
money is the way to go,
because you can.
It'll come to you easier.
You have the leverage of your notoriety
and things of that nature.
And, so, that's the route.
And really for a lot of people,
if you're able to raise money.
The terms of raising money
are so attractive these days,
that you can mitigate a
little bit of your risk
without using your own money.
And loan you're on the hook, and interest,
and things of that nature.
So, to me it's raise money first,
closely followed by using your own money.
Especially if you can afford it,
and especially if you
really believe in it.
But the reason I think raising money
instead of your own money
is a little bit more attractive
is because the people you bring money from
there's dumb money, and
there's smart money.
By bringing in smart money,
people that write
$50-$100,000 dollar checks
that happen to be in that business,
or that can happen to
have leverage to get you
your first five clients.
If you got a wine, spirits,
or social media start up,
I'm a great investor,
because I've got clout in those worlds.
So, I've got my money on the line, right?
And I'm gonna go use my power
to bring opportunity for it.
So, smart money is really
the most attractive.
Then dumb money, just
the money for the money
versus your own money becomes a debate
based on your own financial situation.
Third is the banks. Third.
- [Steve] Last question.
- Nick.
- Hi, Gary. This is Nick Folk
from the New York Jets.
- [Gary] Kicker.
I'm just wondering what are
the few things I can do now
to prepare for business after football.
- So, Nick, I think similar to B Marshall,
there's a lot of networking aspects.
But the other thing I
think you could be doing
especially during the off season.
Let's talk about another thing real quick.
Right now we're very focused on the Browns
and the season.
Guys, all of you, let's not
worry about these answers.
We can focus on that in
February, March, and April.
Let's get really focused on football,
but I got your back Coach Bowles.
But, Nick, I think one of
the things that you can do
is start becoming a
practitioner and an executor
in the place that you're passionate about.
You know, you're gonna kick
out of football at some point,
and what's gonna happen is
you're gonna want to go and do something.
Being good at that actually matters.
If you're passionate about music,
or you want to start a music app,
downloading all the music
apps, reading about music apps,
engaging with people and talking
to them about music apps.
To me the advise here,
and for everybody's who's
watching in the Vayner Nation,
is listen way too any
people want to be something
versus actually putting in the work
to be a practitioner for it.
And a lot of you are jumping
into things, by raising money,
by quitting your jobs, by
putting your other asset
the one you have most,
which is your time between
7 p.m. and two in the morning,
into something without prepping for it.
The amount of people that are
jumping into the cold pool
of business without warming up, right?
The amount of people just
hitting the court without stretching.
The amount of people that are
just jumping into business,
doing no prep work.
By the time I was 22 years
old to run my dad's business,
I'd done eight years of
real prep work, right?
By the time I started VaynerMedia,
you know this thing?
It's not winning by accident.
It's winning, because 2006,
three, four years of
being just a social media
personality and practitioner,
15 years being business.
I've put in the work.
You can't run a marathon cold.
All five of these phenomenal athletes,
they didn't just roll out of bed,
this Sunday morning coming up, and play.
They've been in mini camp,
they've been in training camp.
They've been prepping, they've
been studying the film.
I hope you guys are studying the film.
They've been getting ready for this game.
And, so, way too many
of you entrepreneurs,
and, Nick, the thing that
way too many athletes
take for granted, and celebrities,
and other people that
transition other things is like
cool, you just think because
you were a great kicker
in the NFL, you're gonna
be a great entrepreneur.
It's not just how it works.
You've got to put in the work.
And, so, I would say to you,
and this is why I broke up
you and Brandon's questions
similar points of view.
Brandon and Nick, it's
about not only networking
and having relationships,
but then you've got to be
able to bring tangible skills
to the table.
And, so, that's what I
would be doing, Nick.
Now, getting deeper into your studies
on the thing that you
want to be doing post NFL.
Guys, I mean like, listen.
There's just no, there's
no better show for me
than what's just happened.
Five amazing New York Jets
asking questions for this show.
So, now I'm going to go
into my prediction part.
I'm going to give you a
prediction for this Sunday,
like I'm gonna do every
week prior to the game.
You know, depending on
Thursday, Friday, Wednesday.
Depending on how many
shows I'm taping that week.
And then, I'm gonna give
you the season prediction,
which is the big one.
The sad thing is this
show hasn't been going
around that long,
and, so, you don't know
that for the last four years
NFL seasons, I've been very pessimistic,
and have predicted the Jets
not to make the playoffs
and very worried, and, you know.
5-11, 6-10. I've been
very down, very concerned
about many different things.
And, so, a lot of you don't
know that I'm not normally,
it's the one place where
I'm not a true optimist.
It's been 33 years of tough
pain being a Jets fan.
And, so, however, I have new
found light for this season.
I am very excited.
If the offensive line holds,
if the safety play is
as strong as I'm hoping,
we've got some youngsters.
Pryor, we need a lot from you.
But when I look at that whole situation,
Sheldon coming back
hopefully in four weeks,
maybe in six or eight.
Depending on what the NFL does.
Big Cat 92, like one time Shaun
Ellis, now Leonard Williams.
Looks like a beast, I'm very optimistic.
Mo is as strong as it gets.
You got Batman and Robin in the secondary.
The Batman and Robin
of the receiving core.
I'm obsessed with Quincy number 81 at
H back tight end stuff.
There's a lot of stuff with Devin Smith.
We're about to see what
he can bring to the table.
I'm a big believer in the Coach Bowles.
Fitzpatrick demeanor.
And I think Chris Ivory
is one of the grossly
underestimated running backs in the NFL.
If the special teams could
do a little something,
I'm excited about that.
Chris number 17, I like what you're doing.
And, so, I think that the New York Jets
are gonna go 10 and six.
And here's why,
because I think the Buffalo
Bills are the most grossly
overrated team in the NFL.
Everybody's buying into the hyperbole.
I am completely blown
away by people's belief
that they're going to the playoffs,
and that they're gonna
win nine or 10 games.
It's a five and 11 team, they stink.
And we're gonna find
those openings a victory.
We're gonna lose some games along the way.
I know that most people have
the Jets at five and 11,
six and 10.
I know the most optimistic
have us at nine and seven.
I'm going all in on this team.
I feel it. I feel it in
a big way, 10 and six.
And with that, this Sunday the Jets go out
and beat the Cleveland Browns,
who have not won an opener since 2004.
19 to seven.
And that's my predictions for the season.
I'm excited. We will
track it along the way.
I recognize that I've
put myself out there,
but I believe, baby.
I believe.
Statement of the day.
In that statement,
I'm tweaking it a little
bit for this weekend.
I want your favorite teams
prediction record for the season.
Just to see where you guys are at.
And I'd love to see your statement.
I hope you enjoyed this show
as much as I did.
J-e-t-s. Jets, Jets, Jets.
You keep asking questions, Jet players,
and I'll keep answering them.